wir gehen eigentlich unsere europäischen
nachbarn mit der krise um das wollen wir
uns jetzt genau ansehen denn hier gibt
es wenigstens eine gute nachricht dem im
europäischen vergleich kommt deutschland
ganz gut durch die krise wie diese karte
hier zeigt wir sehen wir sind fast
umgeben von roten und dunkelroten
gebieten tschechien die lage besonders
schwierig belgien frankreich auch dort
schießen die korona zahlen in die höhe
doch im norden in skandinavien da sieht
es noch vergleichsweise gut aus
vielleicht sogar besser als hier
und was können wir daraus eigentlich
lernen und dafür ist jetzt hier bei mir
zu besuch und chefreporter peter ziele
wenn die zeit gesehen skandinavien sieht
super aus was machen die was wir auf
manchmal also erstmal hat skandinavien
in teilen ja diesen sonderweg gehabt
dass man ein bisschen mehr freiheit
gegeben hat aber zur wahrheit gehört
auch skandinavien keine sich teilweise
leisten aufgrund der bevölkerungsdichte
also wenn wir jetzt nach deutschland
gucken und uns gebiete angucken mit
einer ähnlichen bevölkerungsdichte wie
skandinavische länder dann stellen wir
fest wenn wir auf die aktuellen werden
wir auf die aktuellen zahlen des robert
koch institutes gucken die heute kam
dass wir bundesländer haben die sind in
die strukturiert zum beispiel ist
mecklenburg vorpommern hat eine ähnliche
bevölkerungsanzahl wie zum beispiel wie
zum beispiel lettland hat sogar noch
einen niedrigeren wert als lettland wenn
wir gucken sachsen anhalt liegt glaube
ich momentan bei 15,8 das ist es wert
15,8 wir haben auch in deutschen
gebieten die ähnlich besiedelt sind wie
skandinavien ähnliche werte aber in den
großstädten in skandinavien sie zum teil
ein bisschen besser aus als in unseren
großstädten und da scheint es gar nicht
nach einem anderen weg zu sein und
wahrscheinlich sogar auf einem besseren
weg nämlich dass man an bestimmten
stellen mehr freiheiten ist unter
anderem mehr wer einsteigt aber
grundsätzlich gilt desto dünner
besiedelt desto weniger corona danach
kann es ja dort nicht zum lockdown auch
die masken pflicht ist nicht so streng
wie hier die auflagen sind nicht so
streng wie hier gibt es da etwas was wir
uns vielleicht abschauen können dass man
die masken da trägt wo sie wirklich
gebraucht werden also wir haben sehr
regelmäßig von von unserem gegebene
papst herrn zastrow der gerade vorhin da
war dass man die masken oder tragen soll
wo sie auch gebraucht werden also wir
müssen jetzt keine maske tragen weil wir
150 auseinander stehen würden wir
dichter stehen dann müssen wir eine
maske tragen dann bringt die meiste geld
ist also wir müssen nicht zu viele
masken auflagen haben das man haben uns
die schweden vor gemacht sondern da wo
sie gebraucht werden da wo es wirklich
sinnvoll ist da tragen und ansonsten
kann man sich dann auch mal sparen
aber vorsicht ist die mutter der
porzellankiste ich trage sie die wir
einfach öfter als einmal zu wenig ja es
tut ja auch nicht was skandinavien auch
richtig gemacht als wären die schulen
und die kitas die ganze zeit auf
gelassen die mussten nicht einmal
schließen das ist ja hier in deutschland
jetzt ein großes thema alle eltern
fürchten sich davor
warum machen wir es dann nicht einfach
wie die skandinavier und sagen die
bleiben auf also wir machen es jetzt ja
so noch so und bei uns wird viel
gelüftet und wir haben jetzt die wir
haben die erkenntnis dass zum beispiel
kleinkinder oder kinder die im kita
alter sind nicht so ansteckend sind wird
wie es erwachsen sind
damit ist schon mal an einer front schon
mal entwarnung da können wir also die
kinder in die kita schicken wir können
wenn wir müssen durch lüften die kinder
auch in den kindergarten schicken und
auch in die schule schicken das sind
nicht die großen infektionsherde
man muss sich dann überlegen was man mit
den lehrern macht meiner meinung nach
reicht es aus wenn der lehrer im
unterricht eine fb2 maske trägt wenn das
dann irgendwie will dann ist er selber
auch geschützt weil die schutzzeit auf
beiden wegen einatmen ausatmen
das würde reichen und da sind jetzt auf
dem skandinavischen weg zur wahrheit
gehört auch dass in skandinavien dass er
den versuch war die schulen auf zu
lassen das war ein großer test so der
der ist gut gegangen in den schulen ist
er ist ja in schweden gut gegangen in
den altenheim ist gründlich daneben
gegangen also die hohen todeszahlen die
wir aus schweden haben die kommen aus
dem altenheim wenn man die alten nicht
genügend geschützt hat also das eine war
ein versuch offen zu halten wir haben
mutter der porzellankiste hören sehr
sehr vorsichtig wir haben alles
zugemacht jetzt hat sich jetzt gezeigt
wird ein ganz vieles nicht schließen
müssen
der mittelweg ist manchmal der beste ja
daraus lernen wir hoffentlich jetzt für
die zweite welle eine letzte frage noch
peter wir haben gerade gesehen wenn man
es auf skandinavien jetzt konzentriert
um uns herum sieht aber düster aus bzw
dunkelrot wie ist eine prognose was wird
da passieren auch bezüglich der grenzen
eine unserer eu nachbarstaaten
also meine prognose bin nicht gott und
ich kenne auch nicht alles aber meine
prognose ist dass wir zu einzelnen
ländern wohl irgendwann wieder
grenzkontrollen haben werden in nicht
allzu ferner zeit österreich haben wir
die dauer kontrolle haben wir die
genehmigung aus der eu
und es wird wohl demnächst dazu kommt
also wenn es an den grenzen wirklich
also bei und nachbarländern wirklich so
weitergeht dass das wir an den grenzen
zu tschechien und meinetwegen auch zu
holland wieder kontrollen einführen
das heißt dann aber nicht dass kein
pendler über die über die grenze kommt
das heißt nicht dass der warenverkehr
stopp oberste priorität bundesregierung
hat gesagt die wirtschaft muss
weitergehen und die kinder müssen in die
schule kommen dem wird sich der rest
unterordnen und auch grenzkontrollen
werden sich dem unterordnen des wird
kontrollen geben es wird regeln geben
aber es wird keine komplett
geschlossenen grenzen geben
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren